how do you decide what to do when you  feel you're good at a lot of stuff you  pick one so how do you know which is the  right one you don't  you don't and let me tell you a very  important thing I believe one of the  most fascinating excuses in life is that  I'm so good at so many things that I  don't know which one to pick I think  it's an excuse that I think it's ego and  I think it's a vulnerability I think  it's [ __ ] I really do pick one  if you're so good at so many things  you'll pick one you'll be good at that  and you can do a bunch of things I'm  doing a bunch of things I don't want to  waste time because I'm so good at so  many things is an excuse to not do and  it's the worst one because you're trying  to act cool while not doing anything  I mean it man pick something and [ __ ]  do it you're a [ __ ] young kid you can  do all 19 things  you got it you're welcome